let's go to a happy place okay I hope it
was a happy place the Jim Henson working
with Jim Henson was maybe not was he
because he look you you get this sort of
you know in in my my perception I guess
a lot of the people in the world like
you know this quiet reserved uh genius
who uh is humble I I don't know I don't
know anything about him other than he
created the Muppets and and wow this is
great but I'm looking at you right now
and I'm saying well maybe he wasn't the
nicest person to work with
um you know let me say this about
working there
um
I love Kermit okay Kermit is definitely
very special to me why is that
um
I think it's how he copes with being
green I think I think he really is a
Cooper he knows how to just deal with
that
um
and he's just very lovable you know he
really is he um we communed it was good
it was there yeah no he was good
um I think
it's a lot like Beirut you go and he
lets people fight it out he really puts
a group of terrific people together but
they might not all work together well
and you have to sort of fight it out
um it was something
that it was
the only reason I took it was because I
had almost I had lost
two other fabulous jobs because I had a
skiing accident I was supposed to be in
Hannah and Her Sisters I had five scenes
part was just cut out and uh I also was
shooting a television thing and it was
going to be a two-month gig and I had
shot I think a day and I was recast
because I almost died but my life was
saved yeah and so
you know I mean that was a good thing
but things have been going really well
acting wise and that was the period
where and and Jim had see me do Cloud9
Tommy Tunes production of Cloud9 I was a
replacement cast
um brilliant play it was the first it
was how I Got My Equity card actually I
did it for I don't know quite a few
months and what an amazing it was the
triple roll it was fabulous
and I and he had seen me do that I
didn't know it but he had seen me do
that and he knew I was teaching at NYU
Tisch at the graduate program he knew I
was teaching acting stuff and doing
comedy I was doing clown in the
theatrical clown I taught that for years
well yeah but mainly at that point it
was theatrical clown which was really
about finding your own comic Persona
your own point of view of the world and
um just being so present you know
um
and anyway
I think it was just this this tough time
for me and I went well I have to earn
some money and so I said yes I had done
this other so I said yes and then he had
me do this other movie sort of to try me
out and I loved that process it was with
a director named Gavin Miller it was
called
oh uh dream child within home wow Cora
Brown and um Coral Brown and Peter
Gallagher and Jane Asher and I was in
charge of directing the fantasy
sequences for Gavin Miller so I would
direct all of these fantasy sequences
with the Mad Hatter and all of this
stuff and he liked that and and well he
and then he would say yeah how about I
like this version I would do give him
like three choices he'd say I like this
and can you do that you know and it was
great and I loved the way he directed it
was it was super fun even though it was
a like a condensed period And I had
never done any of this before again it
was like you know you're building it
you're you're creating well I didn't
work with you know the animatronics it's
like you'd have all these buttons and
just to do the Mad Hatter mouth there
were seven people on it on the face
seven people you had people doing the
the jaw up and down then you had people
doing the lips you had people doing the
the eyes the eyelids anyone messes up
well exactly and and then you have three
or four characters characters uh in the
same setup and then you have we had a
live British actor who I would have do
the voice I mean it was complicated so
anyway I ended up doing it it was a year
of my life and then I was Frank Oz said
do you want to do Little Shop of Horrors
and do the plant and I went no I think I
want to go back and do acting thank you
very much and I loved Frank I loved Trey
but I I just it wasn't my genre what can
I say I do have him do the Yoda voice no
I didn't no I would have done it you
would just can you ask me in your Yoda
voice and I'll consider it
join me
I'm sorry